I wonder if we might start and we will
to deal with wind rush in just a second
but wonder if we might start with the
local elections and judging from what
I've read I imagine you've got there
bunting out the attic the champagne on
ice no I never I never predict local
elections you just can't that they're
not like a general election or anything
like that very many local factors come
into play so from what we've seen we've
had a fantastic campaign large numbers
of people with our membership knocking
on doors and the feedback is pretty good
but you can never tell until the day
itself and I'm saying to people you know
just be very careful about any
predictions because we've been here
before and you know you get all the hype
and then people can get let down I think
we'll have a good result but we'll see
on the day as I say too many local
factors coming to play to make an
accurate prediction at this stage a good
result and do I detect perhaps a a touch
of expectation management entering the
narrative no mr. Madan no no I I've got
a track record of trying to predict
general elections now not bad on those
one local government I've got an abysmal
track record of predictions so don't
don't rely upon me I think we'll have a
good night because that's the feedback
I'm getting from all the work on the
ground and I've been touring around the
country in the campaigns but local
elections are just really unpredictable
and remember remember we're at an
all-time high in our local government
election results only four years ago on
these seats so it's very difficult to
push the bar even higher but we'll see
on the night we'll see I think we'll
have a good night but as I say it's
difficult to predict you know you're not
going to keep trying to draw you into
specifics I mean others have of course
their predicted great things for labour
particularly in and around London I mean
I'm wondering whether you think that the
the accusations of the allegations of
anti-semitism might have an effect at
the local elections particularly in
places like Barnet what it strikes me
about very might very well might be the
case you can't tell on these things I've
been in Barnet and I've been canvassing
in Barnet that I'm back there next week
and the response on the doorstep three
it seems pretty good I spoke to a group
of young
people at one of the local six form
colleges there and they and the question
did come up you know it was a really
good debate it was a really healthy
debate about how we address
anti-semitism not just in the party but
also in the community and I think on
this issue I think as a community you
know we might come out strengthened on
this because it's highlighted the
seriousness of anti-semitism and it's
focused all our minds now but how we
eradicate it both in the Labor Party but
what came across in the discussions I
had in Barnet I mean our society as well
like I don't think we should tolerate
living in a society where Jewish
cemeteries are attacked and dogged with
swastikas and you have to have security
on Jewish schools that's unacceptable so
if any good is going to come out of this
now certainly it's about cleaning up the
act within the Labor Party but also I
think more widely than that tackling it
with society as a whole it indeed
actually took me to your credit mr.
McDonald you you identified
anti-semitism as an issue within Labor
ranks at pretty early on mr. Corbyn has
caught up with you I do wonder whether
or not you're perhaps slightly annoyed
by the fact that there are others within
the PLP and the wider party who don't
seem to have got the message let me just
correct you on that Jeremy Corbyn hasn't
caught up with me we've been working
hand-in-hand as we're exactly on the
same page and always have been on this
issue Jeremy Corbyn is one of the most
well one of us fundamental anti-racist
campaign is devoting his life to
including tackle yet if you identify it
was only in the past few days no that's
not true he's consistently argued those
at issue here to be addressed and when
commissioned in the chakravarthi report
saw action to address it the fact now
that he's saying look we've got to be
more more thorough on all of this the
new general secretary has been appointed
she's been told that's your number one
priority by Jeremy and that's exactly
what she's doing but let's get the
message clear to every Labour Party
member and every member of our community
we will not tolerate anti-semitism and
any political party right or left or in
our society and we will root it out and
that's what we're doing but what one
person I would imagine that you have the
ITO of his led McCluskey mean he wrote
in the New Statesman this week that
there are Corbin Heat
MPs using anti-semitism to smear the
leader I mean is that you'd assessment
no and Jeremy said that's not his
assessment either but one element of
lame McCluskey's article was an
acknowledgment that there is an issue of
anti-semitism no matter how small the
assessment of it is and it has to be
rooted out so Len accepted there was an
issue here to be addressed and actually
gave his weight but Luis weight behind
addressing you and you know that's what
we'll do I mean well you maybe then be
having a word with you know Chris
Williamson your colleague in the PLP
who's fundraising from our quads worth
at the moment to appeal against his
expulsion from the party I mean mr.
Williamson called it absurd again is
that you'd assessment no I've never
commented on individual cases
particularly if there's legal action or
processes going on because I don't want
to jeopardize the due process on each of
these cases and that will sort of said
to others as well let let you process
take place make sure there's natural
justice make sure their cases are heard
properly and then if people are found
guilty of it there's a whole range of
measures that have to be put in place in
some instances is about re-education
making sure people understand what the
issues in other cases it is say your
behavior is unacceptable you're out of
this party but you know we've got to
have it I'm hoping we have a wider
debate about anti-semitism across the
whole community and now because it isn't
just about cleaning up the actors in the
labour party as I said I'm shocked at
the levels of anti-semitism that there
is within a wider society and I'm hoping
well on a cross-party based on our cross
community basis we can address this
issue thoroughly now but why then did
Jeremy Corbyn not take any of the
suggestions from the Board of Deputies
the Jewish Leadership Council on one
specific issue why shouldn't it be the
case that MPs Labour MPs are told you
will not share a platform with someone
who has been suspended from the party
for allegations of anti-semitism it's
already it's already within the rules
that you do not share a platform with
people have been expelled suspension is
a slightly different matter and that's
one of the issues we've got to discuss
within the party when he met with the
Board of Deputies and the Jewish
leadership
council there was a whole list of issues
that they raised and processes that they
wanted the Labour Party to enact there
was a discussion about how that can be
done in some instances you have to
change the Constitution it takes a while
to do that in other instances I mean the
protection in particular no no but this
was presented to us last week in the
discussion that Jeremy had this agenda
so he's working through and they're
going to meet again in July I think the
Board of Deputies in Jewish Leadership
Council by July we'll see that for
example one of the demands that they had
quite rightfully is processing the
backlog of cases that we've got I think
they'll be pleased with the progress
that we have on that by July on the
other matters where there's some legal
advice that needs to be taken particular
and data protection this issue about a
separate Ombudsman to be looking at
these issues again we can report back
and work through these issues together I
know they weren't over that you know I
know they've been too spirited by that
meeting but that we again we have to
ensure the processes we've put in place
are based upon sound legal advice and
they're not challengeable and then are
effective as well now I think if I July
the next meeting and we're going to be
meeting them on a regular basis now
shall we work together okay okay mr.
Badal and clearly it has been a very bad
week for amber rods
why should she resign if it was an
honest mistake
when she inadvertently misled the house
I mean do you have a do you have a
problem with there being targets for the
removal of illegal immigrants from the
United Kingdom I'm I stand by what
Theresa May said over a number of years
ago when she was a criticizing Labour
Home Office ministers and she basically
said if you make decisions you as a
minister you're responsible for your
department if something goes wrong you
should go now Theresa May was right then
I think we we believe we're right now
amber rod either misled Parliament or
was too incompetent to manage their own
department on either grounds she should
go and it's not me saying this I'm
abiding by the strictures that Theresa
May herself said years ago in opposition
but to be clear on the second part of
the question you personally have
them with their being targets after the
removal of illegal immigrants but I
think what happened was is that the
government conservative government set
ludicrous targets were never going to be
met and as a result of that created what
they called a hostile environment and
that hostile environment led to human
suffering that is unacceptable what
we've always said these targets never
work what you do is you make sure that
Diana Bay said yes the reason the
government would have targets yes you
have a you have a reasonable and fair
system which arrives at reaching a
reasonable level of migration benefiting
the economy and jobs overall that's
exactly what you do and you plan it in
that way you do not set ludicrously low
talks in the way the Conservatives did
which are unbeatable